Okay.
It's time to finish the project.
If you want to follow
along with my solution,
you can download a copy of my source
code in the downloadable section.
I started by creating
new crops of the images.
Some of the images were fine, but for
most of them, I went with different
crops for different browser widths.
For instance, with the horses
on medium sized displays,
I zoomed in just a little bit.
And then on small displays,
I zoomed in quite a bit.
Now, you can actually see the horses.
Back in the HTML,
your picture element has two types
of children, source and image.
Source is optional but image is not.
The image here acts like a fallback,
meaning,
that if none of the sources get hit,
the images will be displayed.
Also for
browsers that don't support picture,
the image will be displayed by default.
For each image,
I set two sources alongside the image,
the first source has a media query
of min width 750 pixels, and
the second has a media
query of 500 pixels.
For each image, I set two
sources alongside the image tag.
The first source has a media query
of min-width 750 pixels, and
the second has a media query
of min-width 500 pixels.
This means that for any browser with
a view port greater than 750 pixels,
the images in this source
stack will be shown.
If the browser has a view port
width greater than 500 pixels, but
not greater than 750.
This source tag will be shown.
And then, for any others,
the last image tag will be shown.
Which means that, basically,
any browser smaller than 500
pixels will be seeing this image.
For the first source, I decided to take
advantage of the source set attribute.
Source set allows you to change
which image is displayed,
based on a device pixel ratio.
So for a 2x display, I am showing a 2x
image which is at 1600 pixels wide.
But for 1x displays I am
just showing a 1x image.
And 1x is default,
it doesn't need to come at the end
with the picture element set up like so
the browser is being told to decide
which image to download based on its
width and its device pixel ratio.
This is really awesome because
you know that the browser is
only going to download the image
that meets its needs perfectly.
Talk about responsible.
And hey, all of this still works within
the figure tag that I was using before,
so here's a figure caption because,
why not.
And, of course, I made sure to
set all of my alt attributes.
The only image that didn't
get an alt attribute is
the SVG logo at the top because it
doesn't really mean anything here.
So, how does all this look?
I'll go ahead and test.
First things first, I'll test whether or
not these images are changing
based on browser width.
So here's the large image of the horses.
At less than 750 pixels, I see a much
tighter crop of them, which looks good.
And then,
once the browser drops below 500 pixels,
there's the tightest crop of the horses.
So it looks like the picture
element is working.
To test whether or not SourceSet
is working, I've gone ahead and
refreshed the page while
emulating an iPad.
With a width of 1,024 pixels and
a device pixel ratio of 1,
you would expect that only 1 x
images are being downloaded.
In fact, that's what you see.
Check out how in the network tab,
only 1 x images are being downloaded.
As a test, I'll change
the device pixel ratio to 2 and
hit Refresh and check it out.
2x images are being downloaded.
That's a pretty clear sign that
the picture element is working awesome.
And then, for the fun of it,
I can even emulate what the experience
would be like on mobile.
I set the network throttling to 3G,
and hit Refresh.
And it looks like the page loads
in just under four seconds,
which all things
considered isn't too bad.
And then, and so, wallah.
There's the blog.
I made a few other changes like
making the top image a full image.
And you can check out those changes
if you check out the source code
in the downloadable section.